donc on est allé dans ton téléphone
franck et qu'on ait des voleurs ici on
va trouver des photos de toi avec celui
regarde ouais avec vignes diesel est
ouest a rencontré jean diesel
ouais le style original mais comment
c'était où c'était à l'époque où je
dressais des animaux pour le cinéma et
c'était sur un film de mathieu kassovitz
à prague je dressais ces gros aucun
décor ceux-là ouais et donc j'ai passé
plusieurs jours à travailler avec vin
diesel et on sent qu'il est heureux de
rencontrer alors une autre photo dans
ton portable qu'on a achoppé
est ce que ces quelques heures avant ou
après le crime celle là heureusement est
l'année du crib examen on avait passé
des vacances ensemble avec malik
franchement tu avais passé les bonnes
vacances et moi oui juste eu cet
incident évidemment quand on cacher si
je peux dire et malik très bon style
dont malik bentalha qu'on embrasse notre
panic qu'on aime regarder genève autrui
ah ouais c'est quoi ça ça c'était
surtout assas et quand tu étais aux
manifs et les journaux
quand je pense qu'à cette heure-là
avant il y avait la paix 1 2-1 édition
avec des débats politiques super
intéressant hélas depuis tout à l'heure
c'est que des conneries
ben c'est 8 m/s et c'est pas toi c'est
lui alors non franck ça c'était sur le
tournage de taxi
oui j'ai fait exploser cette voiture et
je pensais pas que ça allait exploser
aussi fort donc à l'âge et la tête du
mec qui à ultra peur pour de vrai c'est
ça tu te dis ouais c'est parti un petit
peu trop là car oui oui on sait pas que
ça a explosé
alors là bas c'est franck avec stella
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
franck est en pleine négociation peut
l'annoncer la cabrerisse est ta
rencontre et sylvester stallone ouais
mais c'est un grand moment de ma vie on
attend c'est normal c'est mon idole
c'est mon idole absolue ou pas il était
adorable avec moi vraiment en fait
l'histoire est un peu longue mais
j'apprends qu'il va être à cannes je me
débrouille pour aller dans la soirée où
il était invité
je les ai vu au loin il m'a fait comment
donc ça m'a j'étais vraiment là je le
dit en rigolant mais vraiment j'étais
dans un état second et on a discuté un
petit peu et c'est lui qui m'a dit viens
on fait la photo comme ça et puis ce qui
est incroyable avec les américains c'est
que les personnes lui explique qui je
suis j'ai fait le dernier taxi et là en
plus il fait une apparition dans taxi 3
donc il sait très bien ce qu'est taxi et
ça se termine ou le mec lui dit écoute
c'est un des réalisateurs un peu à la
mode en france tu devrais faire un film
avec lui et stallone
comment l'américain tony hawk à la
drogue il serre la main on s'échange les
contacts et ouais ouais c'est ça le
numéro qui veut certainement
non je n'ai pas numéro si tu mens il
mais tu peux jurer et dire je n'ai pas
numéro j'ai pas un numéro sur moi mais
oui je son lot regardez on a trouvé ce
taux de photo cl d'eau franck est envie
de rien ça fait un tabac avec ma maman
ouais j'avais aussi six mois sept mois
non non non oui bah ça va c'était pas
qu'on avait les coupes de cheveux comme
ça c'est lé coup pourquoi les gars on
doit vous rigoler parce qu'il a les
oreilles avec à droite ça passera par le
bronze il a vraiment montré ça
n'arrivait que ce plaisir
[Rires]